muttering ow lee is fighting to save the
rainforest and that entails fighting the
companies that set fire to forests to
clear land for palm oil plantations
global demand for palm oil is soaring
but the booming industry comes at a
price Indonesian now has one of the
world's worst environmental records the
problem is especially acute in Sumatra
when was relives can he gather
sufficient evidence to sue the arsonists
monsoon rains have put out the fires for
now but sumatra is still shrouded in an
acrid haze missouri now lee and his team
are examining a map and discussing their
next mission anyway i'm a bit today
we'll be heading out to some remote
villages in the East that have suffered
serious damage from forest fires i'll be
talking to locals there any c4 mohan on
the 42 year old lawyer and environmental
activist is collecting evidence so he
can sue those he holds responsible for
the devastation when i'll go bare ass up
or come to none in october eighty
percent of Sumatra was engulfed in thick
smoke mother everyone was breathing in
toxic fumes what
yeah any process will you satellite data
to compile maps we've already been on
the ground investigating the forest
clearance in the areas marked in blue
beeping back on we still haven't been
here to the area marked in red blackwell
gotten Gordon take the journey to the
east of the island takes several hours
hey one hotness used to be peatland that
was home to a wide range of biodiversity
the native plants have been replaced
with oil palms look there's a Savannah
monitor lizard you don't see many of
them around here anymore there are no
paved roads here ma zouri will need to
take a boat to reach the village he's
picked up by ahmed a local farmer who
tells him about the recent forest fires
mama at school yeah we immediately
reported the fires to the police but the
local government did nothing and the
regional police did nothing about it the
app it is and I think they want people
to keep quiet about the fires samundar
are a couple technique company bakuman
the pommel company's first promised us
that they would be improving our lives
but I have the impression they want to
destroy the local economy become young
rasa I really hope that these companies
will soon be stripped of their land
rights in our village about me along the
the taboo Indian nepeta vvs2 harapan
camilla ritika dasani
yo yo yo give it up na young
neatza in Indonesia a legal battle is
always complicated in many cases it's
the judges themselves hampering law
enforcement if the defendant can afford
to bribe the judges then a case can drag
on for ages but I still haven't given up
hope that they're still fair judges
besides as I got the village of Sogo has
a population of 300 most people here are
farmers there's only one village school
and no one qualified to give legal
advice Madhuri asks the locals how they
are they were all affected by the fires
Naruto buggy boo boo hamaare the smoke
was a special bad for children as the
elderly the children couldn't go to
school for weeks and we weren't able to
work in the fields we were all stuck at
home Carlos ring
Missouri is helping them write
statements he'll use to build his case
in en de la da da the forms have to be
filled out by a lawyer in Eaton attonnan
by me this is where you need to sign
sadad muscle the palm oil companies are
making our lives very difficult we never
had forest fires here before they
arrived the toxic fumes are terrible the
smoke almost killed me these companies
need to be held to account and that's
why I'm reporting the case defense of
the earth Indonesia the farmers show
Missouri where the fire raged this
channel was built by the palm oil
companies I destroyed the whole peatland
the water drained away through the
channel which meant the ground was dry
and therefore burned more easily one
farmer explains the Missouri that the
tree was so dry it died even before the
fire why do I even wanna dial on he says
the water was so high it came up to his
chest GPS data will help most reproof
that the fire started on land owned by a
palm oil company he's made a number of
attempts to talk to the palm oil
producers but they refused now their
first meeting is likely to be in court
hope nobody gonna get out haha what do
you need in order to sue the palm oil
companies Anthea back from back Adama as
soon as I've collected all the
statements from villagers in the area
I'll submit all my evidence to the court
I'm going to sue 18 palm oil companies
but for now all we can do is pray and
hope that justice will be done
it's not always easy to find witnesses
few local farmers are prepared to speak
out about the slash-and-burn practices
and who's behind them Mohammed is an
exception he's willing to tell Missouri
what he knows but only when the other
villagers are out of earshot the des
koala digan Bangkok in the past when
palm oil companies asked us to clear the
first there would at least be
firefighters on hand but these days they
just go ahead and slash-and-burn often
up to 80 Hector's in one go katanga and
to start with I felt I had to work for
the palm oil companies I didn't have any
other work it was the same for my
friends we all burn the forests did he
break I don't mock solitary hitting but
Mohammed quit he now lives off his
modest rubber plantation so tonight
garlicky terraza can calculate acampo as
a child but I used to love collecting
berries night comedy and watching the
animals in the forest support the mahkum
and yummy sadi there's such amazing
floor and fauna there thank God but the
greed for palm oil has made people
forget that John I do anything to get in
feeding an industry lightened when ma
tree isn't busy working on his case he
spends as much time as possible with his
ten-year-old son of lindo
I'm not having something my dearest wish
is that my son will have a better future
and clean air to breathe that's what
motivates me that's why I'm doing
everything in my power to prevent the
government granting these companies more
land rights so they can carry on
destroying the environment
president is addy I'm not I had the gun
at last we can play football again I
wasn't allowed outside for months my
parents said I wasn't allowed outside
because the pollution would make me sick
mastery is visiting another forest
that's just been cleared most likely to
make way for a palm oil plantation today
he's taking a scooter if he went by car
he'd be too conspicuous his mission is a
dangerous one the palm oil companies are
worth billions and enjoy good relations
with Indonesia's politicians but the
activists refused to be intimidated this
used to be a rich peatland there was
water everywhere the linear yeah slash
and burn practices are rampant across
Indonesia over a hundred thousand have
occurred this year alone now the first
oil palms are growing up out of the
scorched earth ball one knee the
activists are determined to put a stop
to this destruction missouri now Lee has
been campaigning against deforestation
for nearly two decades this red line
marks the borders of the palm oil
companies concessions the arrow in the
middle shows where we are Missouri has
found more evidence to back up his case
the ward yaadon ki dr. Joe connect the
satellite data corresponds to the data
on the palm oil companies land rights
movie on Ibaka huge channel was built
through the area this all suggests that
the palm oil companies were behind the
forest fires Missouri has finally
gathered enough proof to bring a case
but he knows that a legal battle with
mighty palm oil producers will be a
lengthy one and that he only has a slim
chance of winning